Jewish students at Cooper Union are in
the library as protesters pound on the
door listen with the sound on he says
this is this is crazy
listen so they're chanting free free
Palestine while banging on the door
trying to get into a room where they've
secured a handful of Jewish students and
uh let me see what tweets we have Carol
marwick says Jewish students had to be
evacuated via Tunnels for their safety
in New York City uh look I think the
farle I think they're deranged I think
they're psychotic I think they're
dangerous mobs we saw that video out of
Minneapolis where they attacked the
elderly man in his car chased him down
and then tried breaking out his windows
M all because he was like there by
accident oh sorry you kicked the power I
did something yeah you kicked the plug I
did it wrong anyway yeah they they they
tried they they would they'd kill this
guy yeah they because what happens is
it's the snowflake in the Avalanche what
I talk about all the time I don't I
don't think it's fair to say that your
average person at one of these protests
has the has the motive and intention to
kill a person what happens is someone
walks down the street and one person
shoves them the next person runs up and
kicks them the next person runs up and
kicks them again each of them thinking
I'll kick the guy but after getting
kicked five or six times you're dead
yeah and so this is what you see when
this guy is pulling out through this car
I think I think these students if that
door was opened would have been
mercilessly beaten and hospitalized does
anyone have the slightest idea what
these
protesters purported to want to do with
the students well that that's the funny
thing of what you what you was talking
earlier about language right so when we
talk about it here what scares me the
most about this is the use of language
so they're not saying hurt the Jews
they're saying free Palestine which
gives them a sort it allows them to put
like to terroristic threaten these
people without understand without having
to admit that what they want to do is
hurt another person because it's it's
changing the language ever so subtly so
that you don't have to feel as if you're
threatening someone or making
terroristic threats it's very different
and you can make these kids believe that
what they're pushing for is actually a
no anything they don't believe anything
these people are not sitting down and
discussing the merits of the region that
is not what's happening every one of the
protests I've ever been to with these
leftists 90% have no idea what's going
on my favorite moment one of my favorite
moments was during Occupy Wall Street
and what they would what they would
chant the the Communists would chant
Auntie capista they' go ah auntie auntie
capista and okay I get it and you would
hear 90% of the people saying adiga
bisto cuz they have no idea what's being
said let's go Brandon and so there's a
live stream I've got where I asked the
guy I was like what are you chanting and
he's like oh I'm I'm chanting with him
like I know what are you sang and he
goes oh I I don't know he just tries to
walk away giber nonsense they're that's
why those people are so dangerous
they're mindless zombies that's saying
if what they were if what somebody had
got them chanting was a direct threat to
the people in that building would those
same people have followed through and
continued bashing on the door you
believe that they would I believe that
have like I I have been to these riots
the most rabid of them yes no no no no
no the most benol of them the most I
have I have seen people who showed up
not even knowing a PR was happen Chuck a
brick at a cop because when when when
when the Avalanche begins they're all
doing one small thing they don't find
unreasonable a single person picking a
brick out of the ground and chucking at
a person is an extreme act but what
happens is one guy I I this happened in
I think it was uh I can't remember where
it was it might have been DC one guy
starts pulling bricks out of the ground
he walks up the ground and then he
starts like chipping away at The Brick
another guy walks up and then pops up
another guy walks grabs it then one guy
toss it to a guy then the guy gets it
and just throws it yeah that guy has no
idea what's going on not that that was
not the actions of one person who
consciously decided to pick up a brick
and then throw it at a cop it was a
bunch of people screaming in Anger not
paying attention and then all of a
sudden someone tosses a brick to him and
he catches it and he just Chucks it
without without a second thought look
when they went to Tucker Carlson started
banging on the door or when they when
they went to Cassandra Fairbanks house
with a bunch of fireworks and started
blasting met her house then the media
lied about it even happening listen the
problem here isn't these animals they're
a problem but they're not the problem
the problem is that the institutions
that have been given and accepted the
responsibility for protecting human
beings from
animals have refused to do so well and
they've refused to do so not just in a
physical sense right they've refused to
do so in an intellectual sense so the
institutions that are supposed to be
raising our nation's leaders to be you
know thought leaders to be intellectual
to be critical thinkers to think deeply
to examine all sides of an issue to make
decisions in a good and appropriate and
moral and ethical way they have
abandoned their obligation to do that
and they have instead force-fed them
indoctrinated them in these wasteful
ideologies that are intent essentially
on destroying American culture and
Society yes that's true but this is that
is not what we are seeing here no these
are monsters these these students don't
know what's going on don't care what's
going on all they know is one of their
friends says are you going to the
protest they went K and then they said
here's here's this here's the time and
the date and they showed up then people
started chanting something so they
chanted along the people banging on the
door right now that individual banging
on the door just thinks they're making
noise they don't think in their mind
they're terrorizing people but the other
people behind them hear the banging and
the fervor and they're Imagining the
people banging on the door are trying to
bust it down to hurt people mhm so when
the door finally breaks open and they
all rush in one person in a mask is
going to run up and smack one of the
Jewish students and then someone seeing
that will start filming and chasing
after and then you I've seen this in
person I was in San Jose at a trump
rally and I watched them beat one of
their own one of their own protesters so
what happened was why did they do that
they did not know who he was and it did
not matter the moment he backed away he
became an other to the Mob and they
chased him and started punching him why
because he was running that's it they
chased him down punched him in the mouth
and I and and then I was like I'm I'm
I'm I'm here protesting Trump they they
punched me bleeding from the
mouth there's a crowd of people one of
these guys and that's why I said like
these things are ridiculously dangerous
it's
mindless when a scuffle breaks out I'll
give you another story I was at uh
Columbia University Mike cernovich was
speaking this is several years ago and
one person in the crowd recognized me
and didn't like me so he yelled that's
Tim P do not let him film you so you
know what I did when he pointed I looked
with where he was pointing cuz I know
how these mobs operate everybody turns
into my in my direction and they're
looking for the person against them so I
turned with them and I'm going like
where's he at and everybody's shrugging
like where's he at and he's like this
guy right here and I'm
like and then someone walks up to a
random photographer and starts screaming
at him about he's the problem and I'm
like cuz they couldn't identify the
other cuz I know what these what happens
these events you go to one of these
protests and if you are discernably
other one person will push you then as
soon as the fighting happens and you
start running away they'll start chasing
after you for no reason just because
they're like oh they're running I'm
running then when they see other people
running after them they'll be like
what's happening what's happening why is
he running get him get him then they
shove you down and start kicking you
literally for no reason right we've seen
this in our literature for years too I
mean it's in Orwell it's in Kafka it's
in Ray Bradberry it's was in uh was in
Germany we were in uh Hamburg during I
think it was the G20 and Luke was B was
was with a German journalist walking
down the street when some random dude
yelled Nazi schwein hund at him and then
he was like what and then all of a
sudden random people who were sitting on
the ground ran up and started punching
Luke in the back and in the head and
then Luke and this journalist not Nazis
were there just filming things started
running people were chasing them they
made it to First Responders who then
treated them for scra and bruises and
it's and and watch Luke's video of this
it's a question of why did these random
people who were just sitting on the
ground run up and start punching Luke
for no reason this is what these mobs do
so you're saying they're just driven by
themselves they're just like driven by
it's like a feeding fzy like a shark
shark piranhas it's it's or those Shar
that like watch the video of the of the
car in Minneapolis that drove through
the protest very slowly nobody got hit
as soon as he starts driving away people
will run after the car and it's it's
innocuous it's a person will have a
camera and they'll run towards the car
just to film it people behind him see
him chasing the car so they chase then
the whole crowd sees a bunch of people
running and they all run to see what's
going on eventually they surround the
car and then someone goes that's him no
one has any idea or any information and
then one guy who hears that thinks he
must be a bad guy and starts kicking and
stomping on the car other people join in
old guy in the car is freaking out why
am I being attacked and then tries to
escape imagine what it says to these
students to when the university does not
have the people protesting violent
violently removed but instead has to
evacuate them as if they were being
rightfully targeted rightfully targeted
right so what does that say to them that
they're not actually there to protect
you the one who's being assaulted the
one who's being you know we saw this in
University of Washington as well so
there were these big basically pramas
protests at the University of Washington
and some students were speak like a Dean
was there and some students were
speaking to the dean saying you know
these people want us dead they want to
kill us and the dean was trying to get
the students the Jewish students who
were complaining about it who were in
tears trying to get them to move on and
stop complaining about it so that the
pro terrorist mob could continue their
protest which they're doing in your live
chat right now by the way oh really oh
my God I mean there are three or four
people who just keep repeating the
same thing I mean it it's wild I don't
welcome to the internet yes well you
have become a crypto Jew uh that's not
true Cassandra Fairbanks are Booker
proves that we're actually anti-semitic
no no that's that is so you're both Jew
and anti-semitic at the same time that's
amazing well that's okay because the
Jews are both uh are both um you know
control the world's money supply and and
also SC people who who are scavengers
who live off
the thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net